but we do have the winner of the round
from group a Christopher you
congratulations on your win so you've
been playing some really exciting chess
and we wanted to look at both of your
games from yesterday and today so let's
start with today's game Let's uh take us
through the key moment of this game
um
so first of all Queen B6 is a strange
looking move but um it's to prevent D4
and it was kind of some preparation for
this game and after Queen B6 he seemed
to be already out of Series so he was
spending a lot of time from move five or
so
so we went B freeze and natural move D5
Bishop B2 Bishop E7 and it looks like he
was just playing safe safe chess I think
that's generally his style to play
relatively positionally and
let's try to slowly out for you 95 is
very much in his style and I take C6
Queen takes C6 Knight C3 B5 yeah I'm
excited to get like this
Pawn wall A5 B5 c5d5 and you manage so
you had a really nice Pawn wall here so
when did you start thinking that you
your position is or you're doing well
already
I still felt like it was just a normal
position I didn't feel like I was doing
well or badly okay
so Rook d8 so just putting everything in
this
yeah here I started to get complicated
when I proceed for
Queen B1 94.
I think he should have just put like
Bishop D4
or something Queen B2 B Tech C4
um like Bishop takes E4 B takes C4 and
sorry what did you say after Bishop D4
what
before
yeah and it starts getting quite
problematic um okay because you cannot
take back so you have to take care Queen
takes B5
so what was your plan then after Bishop
D4
um I was considering Bishop C5 maybe
yeah
[Music]
because it takes
C5 Maybe
Rook takes C5 and Bishop takes E4 D
takes E4 okay CJ C4 B4
and then yeah and just play this
position
how would you evaluate this position
um maybe some compensation for black
okay so instead instead he went D3 yeah
maybe D3 is fine and I went Knight D2
and starts getting very complicated it's
a funny variation with Bishop D4 I think
he should have played Bishop D4 because
they have to play Queen takes D4
he takes D4 Knight takes B1
Curt takes E7 C takes B3 Rook takes B1
V takes A2 we're getting one and Bishop
C6
or takes A2 A4
and apparently there's actual
compensation for the piece because it's
hard for him to deal with P4 B3 all
right because this piece is started oh
this bishop is just yeah kind of silly
here so this is how you play every game
you just give up a piece for past funds
um did I also sacrifice the piece
yesterday against Abby
and
uh yeah yeah yesterday you're I guess
it's a reoccurring scene in this
tournament so far so that's the key for
your opponents to make sure yeah you
don't get a lot of fun so just straight
fonts in the beginning and then
everything is good
so queen of two Bishop takes E1 Queen
takes E1 V takes A2 Rook A1
B4 and yeah this was kind of part of my
calculation so vertex A2 V3 and I was
really hoping that he played Bishop D4
so I'm able to sacrifice my queen and he
was actually generous and
um so what else can he do here but it's
difficult because because I always have
Rook C2 but I think Queen takes A5 is
what I thought was the best one before
because Queen takes A5 or takes A5 Rook
C2 Bishop D4
V2 revision takes B2 Rook takes B2
Bishop takes D5 I thought this should be
draw yeah
so you think he was being ambitious with
Bishop D4 I wonder if he overlooked
Queen takes D4 yeah
Overlook yeah so he you take and it's
here yeah he could defend my Pawn
because it's not that let's say queen A1
Rook C2 Bishop F3
rookie eight because Bishop D1 Ricky won
um
the problem is this T3 Pawn because just
stopping the Knight and blocking this
bishop it's actually quite annoying so
you went King F1
Bishop C6
Bishop D1 Rook D2
this should be three and now
it's completely dominating this night
and I think he's um lost at this point
Queen C3
oh yeah Bishop takes A2 I think human
Bishop takes A2 yeah take the pawn queen
C3 and now just one more nice move or
ee2
other otherwise um let's say Rook takes
A2 Queen takes C6
he's probably holding because Rook E2
Queen C8
G4 Perpetual yeah this is very annoying
but if Rook E2 first
and I have now I have vertex F2 check
intermedium over takes eight and then I
I checked the engine briefly and
apparently Rick takes A2 almost messed
up the win because he had Queen F6 which
apparently holds the game oh with a
Perpetual it
I I think I have to go like Rook G2 Rook
takes H2 wait no not Rick takes H2 I'm
not perpetual
engine was still saying like minus one
somehow so there was a
um
it looks like Perpetual to me so yeah
yeah
I'm very happy they have two rookie too
oh then rookie too yeah come on down
here okay
GF wait Rick takes H2 it takes H2 but
how wise ah because you how is this not
perpetual
oh but
yeah it remains difficult yeah if I
check and take is this
it's probably winning in the long term
eight so yeah
but I mean this white is so happy to get
this right compared to what happened in
the game
so rookie two so instead of taking on A2
what should you do
um
can you go F3 I think throw in a check
first let's say vertex F2 King G1 ice it
says like for G2 check
then work
I cannot mean
[Music]
so here again so we stop the track
so King has to go to F1 yeah
and
where's the word wait now big over gf2
vertex A2 wait this is the same thing
yeah this is very difficult to figure
out yeah so it's so maybe if
you have Queen CA Queen G4 yeah okay
that's the perpetual
okay we can check
so Rook D2
oh so you go here here here and Rook C2
ah because okay this is very same team
as you had in the game so you're
threatening me
but anyways he wasn't able to find a
defense after Rick takes A2 we'll sit
down on time yeah I only had one minute
even Queen takes D5 and H6 was nice and
he simply has no checks yeah because we
showed us that if you try
F3 unfortunate Perpetual in the dark
Square so H6 and yeah this is just
indefensible he takes Rook C2 and
one of them will deliver meat very nice
game thanks and uh so I have to
just give me a second so I can find how
to find my game yesterday yes but no I
went to the wrong one
so and then I saw that Anish giri
commented that it was from his chorus
but I don't know if it's the new course
or is the course that's been published
or hasn't been published and he's doing
a new course
so tell us about this game yeah this was
a crazy game so how much of it was your
prop
to move 20 or so
I had this bishop G2 Bishop takes F6 so
is this all your analysis or this is his
course oh um this was on my analysis so
before G5 did he was he also playing so
he was also playing quickly did you talk
to him after the game
yeah so we analyzed the variations
there's a lot of interesting moments so
was he also in his proper idea I'm
assuming you have to be here yeah
we're divorce okay so you played rookie
one so just tell me when you're out of
book
um the move 22 so 95 we should see it uh
so Rook F1 F1 so this is the last movie
you know and he went Rick D4 so what
were you expecting here B6 and what's up
Knight C4 Bishop B7 yeah
and how would how do we evaluate this
um like zeros yeah
but it's easier to play for white
because you have to
you can go like b2a3 and just play the
position
and that's just kind of maybe Queen H7
at some point start collecting
on a very good day so instead he won
Rook D4 so this is the first the thing
you take in the game okay so I see you
spend like 18 minutes
um so did you so when he plays Rook D4
and it's not your prep so you thought
this is already a mistake
I wasn't sure yeah but I know you what I
knew it wasn't the best move
but it was it was difficult to figure
out over the board but I think I made a
good decision to play Knight E4
because Rick takes before Queen H5
and I've read that Rick takes F7
[Music]
so instead he went B6
and ah you're actually on the other side
of your opponent having a lot of fun so
even citrian things got really crazy
here did you consider anything else here
Queen H7 yeah
it's a grenade seven he has to play I
think King f8 is his only move because
what happened you just Queen G7 27 2017
Knight F6 Queen G5
yeah 95 this looks quite bad so okay so
he will play here
Knight takes G5 yeah workout four
okay what happens if I take over 6 out
of seven yeah Knight takes up seven in
case of seven b takes C5
and your claim is this king is too weak
the specimen do you have a strong Pawn
Yeah
yeah that's a strong claim okay so here
I have to play work at four
and I didn't really like this that much
during the game but apparently it's
better after Knight C4
this is a good imbalance
so yeah people I cannot untangle yeah
okay so let's go to the game because the
game was quite exciting so this happened
Queen E7 this position looks very iffy
because of his King situation
but it's not as it's not so easy to
Checkmate but
it really felt like I should have a
better position during the game here and
you also had a
um like an hour on here 40 minutes on
him so Rook C1 which is a mistake so
what did you think your plan is to try
to clean this fan or go after his king
or like what how are you just trying to
go after the king or just yeah
all right 57 95 Queen itself and yeah
here Knight D3 was a really strong move
and he has nothing to do about 95.
oh because even here in here yes this is
just Queen G6 did you consider the
circle game
it's hard to say I was considering 94.
for some reason I I saw 94 and then I
didn't see Knight D3 because it takes
Rook F1
immediately
the problem with Knight E4 this is such
a fun impossible yeah
is King E7
Knight takes G5 Queen f8 oh
it's kind of ridiculous but yeah
hurricane F6
continue
page six yeah
so here you already have to start going
back and you didn't
is this so bad
if I go Queen G3
so I doubt it's I feel like wagga's
counting point of Queen F6
so many points yeah I wanted to play
Queen A3 like if you want that for my
idea B5 Queen A3 is is a is actually a
plan so so it's it's yeah yeah but okay
four is a very ugly move to play yeah
okay so where are we kind of got lost in
let's go back to the game yeah so queen
of seven and then you decided hey when
you're upon yeah but unfortunately my
Pawn cannot green easily because he has
this move E4 blocking my Bishop
Queen H3
Queen F6
yeah here I could have won Queen A3
Queen A3 B5 yeah this is variations are
crazy like E4
B5
D3
king beef
King B1
King F7
Knight takes D7 Queen D4
this is what I saw at the end and after
the game oh okay I was gonna tell us if
this is oh the king just runs to safety
King G6 King H6
the position is just
crazy it's kind of funny because now
your queen feels like out of the game
sort of because those funds are running
and the King goes to safety and your
queen would be in rather be on H5 maybe
now
okay so 97
so all of this happened the Knight takes
D7 was bad I simply missed so okay let's
go Knight takes C7 King takes D7 Queen
D3 E4 it takes D3 King B3 I kind of
hallucinated rook d8 and I realized that
I really messed things up and this Pawn
on D3 is really strong
but the game goes on but um so did you
think you're in the other Adventure here
already yeah oh you think you're already
intention because the spawns are
cleaning so you miss Rook d8 or you
thought you have something when I play
Knight takes D7 okay
so he found a very nice resource E5 and
now he's just pushing his pawns and then
you still had some winning chances in
the end I believe
right so around here yeah
so all of this happened so there's one
Queen
yeah this was very funny yeah
yeah is that he took and he we found
Queen E3 after the game but he didn't
see it during the game like a Queenie
free King G5 and now it's tough to
defend
I pawn I just Pawn on B4 that's pretty
strong
he has a lot of checks that he has to
deal with his King is shaky and like
kind of in danger but Bishop D3 was not
good if I went B5 yeah this is very
tough for him because his King is very
bad on F5 because he cannot push this
Pawn right he's I think F3 somehow yeah
with something like
yeah a bunch of checks and Queenie for
Queen F3
so but uh so in this kind of position
like how do you approach this because
you have an r on your clock so do you
spend a lot of time
do you make a decision here
I really I really should have spent a
lot of time in this position well I mean
now it's easy to say right because you
haven't made a mistake during the game I
just got tempted to to take the pawn
with check with Bishop D3 but
um if I had spent maybe like 10 minutes
I could have figured out that P5 was
better
but yeah it is pretty difficult so this
is this is really this kind of
complicated position I think you should
spend
a lot of time but um I I don't know I
felt like it had kind of gotten out of
hand at this point so
maybe psychologically I should have just
reset and still tried to take my time
and make good moves yeah yeah I think
this is like the most difficult thing in
when there is a big shift in the
position to kind of bring yourself back
psychologically and not just um kind of
Lose Yourself and get too emotional
so okay so here um
so you played Bishop D3 and you took the
pawn so Dave did you feel like you're in
danger here and you already have to try
to force a draw are you like happy with
the throw or you still feel like I was
in danger but um I didn't feel like it
was winning anymore let's say yeah so
when did you feel like the game
completely you lost complete control of
the game at which point when I went um
Knight takes D7 oh yeah I wanted to say
don't say 97 but okay so from then on
you just thought things got completely
out of hand
so I can get four P5 so
yeah and then I saw this part yesterday
and there were a lot of there's a lot of
crazy
moves but it was a and it all it ended
up in a drawn position yeah and then you
just agreed here
so how did you
did very very
crazy and shaky from both sides but it
was it was um interesting it was a fight
yeah it was it was a good fight how did
you feel about the game was he happy
with the results I think he was happier
than me because his position was very
shaky while I was mostly pressing
so he seemed pretty happy to defend the
position
you know yeah it was it was a fun game
despite all the mistakes
um there were a lot of interesting
moments yeah this was a really
really yeah we really enjoyed it
and today was also very interesting so
really appreciate you playing this kind
of chance and
uh we look forward to you playing more
exciting games and hopefully we see you
again after more wins so thank you for
joining us thank you